well new at 4 democratic senator jackie  rosen is introducing a plan to make  federal money available to help schools  beef up mental health services now this  is a topic our very own brian loftis  reported on just last night the ccsd  reported 20 suicides in the first year  of the pandemic now the senator is  working to move money that's already in  the federal budget to help students k  through 12 get the support they need  the loss of loved ones maybe not seeing  their grandparents  loss of school their parents may have  lost their job all of the effects of  covid just made it so hard for our kids  or people's grandkids  well the money already goes to colleges  and universities for mental health and  substance misuse services rosen's  proposal has bipartisan support in the  senate